[Music]
ah okay so i've been sick
for a couple days i'm still sick
let's see what has happened
while i was gone you need to see jake
paul's music video
he dissed you jake paul dissed you
holy [ __ ] jake paul roasting pudding
that's so lit
ah you better watch out t
no
not jp not jp how bad is it
how what did he say what did he say in
his video on youtube
in six months all the competition man
pewdiepie is next no
this makes me so angry i'm still sick
calm down felix
oh that son of a [ __ ] i bet he's the
one that poisoned me
oh i bet it was jp all along that sleek
son of a [ __ ] ah we haven't watched
this whole thing yet
we have to see the whole thing
first of all who the [ __ ] is jp who the
[ __ ]
is jake paul i don't know i ha he has
fun
okay he eats food
he's dirk from disney channel okay so
he's a distant channel
one of these disney channel actors
that's cool
can't be that bad let's listen
always appreciate a good ya and the
beginning of a song
for no reason i'm gonna gonna try not to
pause every
every millisecond of this song but yeah
that is a good yacht we have to
appreciate that that's a good that's the
good yacht
y'all don't know what's about to happen
baby
[Music]
like you play some rap music right
that's free
[Music]
see where the [ __ ] is it
i'm glad i'm glad we got the whole uh
disney channel thing
out of the way from the first [ __ ]
line
hey guys in case you didn't know i'm on
disney channel
how can i say that in a way that makes
sense hey everyday bro
disney channel flow bob mill on youtube
in six months never done before past all
the competition man
pewdiepie is next he's saying that i'm
not his competition because he said he
passed all his competition
which basically puts me
what does that put me actually i'm
really confused jp you're going to have
to
re er rate
reiterate all the competition man
pewdiepie is next
[ __ ] i got the shapes again god damn it
jp you son of a [ __ ] how dare you
how dare you use my name in the video
how
dare you and i'm popping all these
checks got the brand new rolex and then
at the lambo too
and i'm coming with a crew this is team
10 [ __ ]
who the hell sipping you and you know i
kick them out
if they ain't with the crew yeah i'm
talking about you
you begging for attention that it may
sound here like that
his flow is all off uh it may it may
sound
completely terrible but really here what
jp is doing is
a new form of rapping it's meant to
sound like [ __ ] and you know i kicked
them out
if they ain't with the crew yeah i'm
talking about you
you begging for attention yeah i'm
you begging for attention i it's just
how you rap
you just say a bunch of words and they
that sounds totally whack
and i i swear i'm not on crack and
i i just like to smack that booty
back yeah and i'm talking about you
it's absolutely incredible this sort of
rapping takes incredible skills
it takes intellect it takes talent
it takes years of grinding years of
training
years of preparation it takes talking
[ __ ] on twitter it takes all kinds of
it takes so much [ __ ] and and
and jake paul will know because he eats
food this is team
10 [ __ ] who the hell
yeah i'm is about you you begging for
attention talking [ __ ] on twitter too
but you still hit my phone last night it
was fo 52 and i got the text approved
i don't understand what the [ __ ] is
happening here is he talking about his
ex or some [ __ ] like that please
let that okay i mean it's it's genius
that's what it is
it's it's really did he make this just
for this is this why i'm reacting to
this because he argued with his
girlfriend
it was paul 52 and i got the text
approved and
all the recorders too don't make me tell
them the truth and
damn damn he goes j if jp breaks up with
you he goes hard and all the recordings
too
it's that is lyrical mind blast
there's meaning behind every syllable
every line
every official expression tells an
incredible story
it was fall 52 and i got the text
approved and
all the recorders too don't make me tell
them the truth and i just dropped some
new merch and it's selling like a god
church
oh and by the way i just dropped some
new merch
he [ __ ] about his girlfriend for for
a couple lines and they
oh by the way got new merch it's selling
like a god church
what is a god church ah it's a church
with a god in it what do you think of
what are you stupid
a god church you never heard of one of
those it's selling like a god church
i love how they clearly got stuck here
hey
hey okay all right we got i dropped some
new merch uh how
it's selling like uh what rhymes with
merch
uh church it's selling like a church
[Music]
legit like i wish that illness killed me
now i i
i'm not joking at all i wanna die
i wanna i wanna be dead now i don't
wanna i don't wanna no
no i don't wanna anymore the tattoo just
for fun
did he get a tattoo of a dick on his leg
the tattoo just for fun
i usain bolt and run catch me at game
one
[Music]
what is that what is
what is that what is that thing
he's absolutely perfect i never seen a
more beautiful man
in my entire life and no i'm not from
cotton
[Music]
england england
hmm oh england is your city
oh no oh no yo you're [ __ ]
oh my favorite ship is the whole planet
and no i'm not from cotton england is my
city and if it were for teens
then the us would be shitty i'll pass it
to chance because you know he say
litty i like how he uh he's so fat that
he
straight up destroy this jacket like
look how it's
hanging by literally it's last threat
it's every day bro
the competition shook these guys up on
me
i
[Music]
well anyone that talks like that i don't
want them to educate me
let me educate you and when i ain't
talking
back what i love most of all about jp is
that is
besides all his success he remains
humble
yes they all copy me but that's some
shitty clones stay in all designer
[Music]
i think this song has killed me i wanna
die more than i've ever died before
someone please don't call an ambulance
let me just never return this is it
guys i'm i it's been great
it's been great let's see what some
other people thought about
jp's wonderful song i like how the
lyrics are on screen man
oh that's always a plus in a rap song
the lyrics just match like
they're white the lyrics just match like
the lyrics just match what
you can't just say that and then say
nothing please say something else
the lyrics just match like you already
dad
i think we all can draw some inspiration
from that now excuse me while i'm going
to kill myself
[Music]
you